اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض نرصده معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
الغرب ويقول ان نهايه العالم اصبحت نوويه
ويتوعد بحرب مدمره اذا اعتقل بوتين
الجيش الصيني يتاهب ويعلن ابعاد مدمره
امريكيه من البحر الجنوبي وهو شنطن تنفي
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يتفق مع نظيره
الايراني على لقاء قريب تمهيدا لفتح
سفارات وقنصليات البلدين
تحرك شعبي فرنسي غاض ضد قانون التقاعد
والسلطات تستعد للخميس الاسود
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا وكل عام وانتم بخير اكد
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
في تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه قد يؤدي الى
نشوب حرب نوويه وحذر من ان اي محاوله
لاعتقال الرئيس الروسي في الخارج بقرار من
المحكمه الجنائيه ستكون سببا بل سيكون
سببا كافيا لاندلاع حرب مدمره وردا على
تصريحات وزير العدل الالماني الذي شدد على
ان برلين ستعتقل بوتين في حال وصل الى
اراضيها ان ذلك سيكون اعلان حرب على روسيا
التي ستقوم بدورها بحشد كل وسائلها
العسكريه المتوفره ومن بينها الصواريخ
لاستهداف المؤسسات الالمانيه واشار الى ان
قرار الجنائي الدوريه غير قانوني وغير
معترف به من جانبه قال السفير الروسي في
واشنطن اناتولي انتونال فان دور الغرب
بقياده الولايات المتحده بقرارها تصدير
ذخيره تحوي اليورانيو المنظم الى اوكرانيا
تدفع العالم الى خط
وراءه كارثه نوويه بدورها اكدت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو لن تترك عزم
بريطانيا امداد اوكرانيا بذخيره تحوي
اليورانيوم المنظم دونارد في المقابل
اعلنت نائبه وزير الدفاع البريطاني انه
الى جانب توفير الدبابات القتاليه
لاوكرانيا فان لندن ستزود كييف بالذخيره
لما في ذلك الذخيره الخارقه للدروع التي
تحتوي على اليورانيوم المرطب
[موسيقى]
تطور الصراع في اوكرانيا لحرب النوويه عاد
للواجهه من جديد
التعهد البريطاني جلب الردود افعال
الروسيه لو تحققت فربما تنقل الصراع في
اوكرانيا الى مرحله مخيفه الرئيس الروسي
حذر من ان بلاده ستضطر الى الرد وتعمل غرب
بنشر اسلحه تحمل مكونا نوويا التحذير
الروسي شمل واشنطن رغم نفي البنتاجون اي
دور لبلاده في هذا الشان
واضح ان الغرب قرر محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكرانيا ليس فقط بالكلام بل بالافعال اذا
حصل هذا الشيء فستجد روسيا نفسها مجبره
على الرد بما يتناسب مع تزويد الغرب
لاوكرانيا باسلحه نوويه
بريطانيا من جهتها بدات غير قلقه من سيل
الوعيده الروسي بل علقت بسخريه على ما صدر
عن الكرملين ووصفته بالتضليل المقصود
واقرت الدفاع البريطانيه ان جيشها يستخدم
اليورانيوم المخطب في قبائفه الخارقه
للدروع منذ عقود هذه النوعيه من القذائف
خطيره على البيئه حيث قالت الامم المتحده
انها قد تشكل مصدر قلق بيئي في اوكرانيا
لما قد تسببه من امراض بما في ذلك خطر
الاصابه بالسرطان حنان المصري العربيه
ومن موسكو مشاهدينا تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه كاتيا طعم اهلا بك وبدايه كيف
يتفاعل ملف قذائف اليورانيوم في موسكو
والى اي مدى ترى فيه روسيا ايضا تصعيدا
جديا وخطيرا هذه المره
مرحبا احمد بالفعل التصريحات السياسيه او
تصريحات الرسميه في السلطات الروسيه لا
تتوقف منذ اعلان بريطانيا طبعا رغبتها
امنيتها ارساق غذائف اليورانيوم الى
اوكرانيا طبعا هو الان فقط سياسي على
الارض لم لم ينعكس لم ينعكس لان بريطانيا
حتى الان لم تحدد موعد ارسال هذه القذائف
الى اوكرانيا ولكن اخر تصريحات كانت على
اولا لسان السفير الروسي لدى واشنطن الذي
اكد ان في حال ان الغرب يدفع العالم الى
حرب عالميه ثالثه بالاضافه الى ذلك نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي مثل مدريد اتاكد
ايضا ان هذه الخطه هي فقط ستؤدي الى
مواجهه نوويه طبعا كان الرئيس الروسي قد
قال ان روسيا ستقوم بالرد في حال تم
استخدام هذه القذائف القذائف اليورانيوم
التي ترسل الى اوكرانيا ولكن روسيا حتى هي
ملتزمه كما تحدث ايضا وزير الخارجيه
الروسيس رياضه ظروف انه
مرتزمه بالعقيده النوويه
ولكن طبعا كان قد تحدث وزير خارجيه روسيه
استخدام مثل هذه الخزائر في اوكرانيا التي
ستؤثر على المواطنين هناك وعلى صحه
المواطنين الى عقود في المستقبل وستؤثر
على التربه تربه
التربه الاوكرانيه وعلى المحصول الذي
سيخرج فيما بعد وكما تحدث ايضا الرئيس
مجلس الدوما كانت قال ان هذه في حال تم
استخدام مثل هذه الخزائر ستؤثر على
الاوروبيين وان الغرب يسعى الى قتال هناك
ليس فقط حتى اخر اوكرانيا ولكن حتى اخر
اوروبي مسلسل تسليح اوكراني هذا مسلسل
مستمر ويبدو انه يمضي بشكل تدريجي لكن هل
هناك نقطه معينه يرى عندها المسؤولون
الروس ان انها تجاود بمثابه تجاوز الخطوط
الحمر والتي يجب ان تتخذ عندها موسكو
موقفا حاز ما
كانت قد تحدثت ان الغرب هو
هو طرف في هذا النزاع بسبب تزويده المستمر
للاسلحه في اوكرانيا طبعا اعلان لندن
ارسال قذائف اليورانيوم وبالاخص هذا
الاعلان ياتي بالتزامن مع زياره الرئيس
الصيني الذي كان يحمل طبعا خطه السلام كما
تعلم احمد هي تاتي طبعا خطوه تصعيديه
جديده وهذا ما اكد عليه وزير الدفاع
الروسي الذي قال ان العالم اقترب خطوه نحو
حدوث مواجهه نوويه اذا الخطوط الحمراء هي
طبعا تزويد اوكرانيا بمزيد من الاسلحه
وبالتالي او نوع جديد من الاسلحه وهي
الاسلحه النوويه التي قد طبعا تعتبرها
موسكو
تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء التي تضعها طبعا في
سياستها
ايضا بشان اعتقال رئيس بوتينغ هل تمضي
جميع تصريحات اساس الروس في هذا السياق
المهدد لاي دوله تفكر في اعتقال رئيس
بوتين على خلفيه المذكره المذكره الجنائيه
الدوريه ام ان هناك استراتيجيات اخرى
تتبعها القياده الروسيه في هذا الشان
روسيا كانت قد رفعت دعوه اولا على المحكمه
الجنائيه التي هي ليست عضوه فيها واعتبرت
ان ونددت بهذا الاعلان اعلان اعتقال
الرئيس الروسي والذي اعتبرته
اليوم بمثابه اعلان حرب ضد روسيا طبعا
روسيا لا تعترف بهذا الاعلان اعلان
الاعتقال هي تقوم باجراءات قانونيه الان
لرد على هذا الاعلان الذي تحدثت عنه
المحكمه الجنائيه احمد
وصف المدير العام لوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفع الجورسي وصف الوضع في محطه
زابوريجا للطاقه النوويه في جنوب شرق
اوكرانيا بانه لا يزال محفوفا بالمخاطر
بسبب استمرار عزل المحطه عن شبكه كهربائيه
متخصصه بل مخصصه للحالات الطارئه منذ
الاول من مارس
بان القطاع الخط الكهربائي عن اكبر محطه
للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا سببه ضربه
صاروخيه روسيه هذا هو حذر خبراء من مخاطر
انقطاع امدادات الكهرباء عن انظمه التبريد
في محطه لفترات طويله اعرب رئيس الاوكراني
عن شكره وتقديره للجنود لدفاعهم عن الخطوط
الاماميه للبلاد بعد ان زار القوات
المحاربه في منطقه باقليم دومباس والتي
تقع فيها بخموت التي تعد محور القتال
الرئيسي بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
منذ الصيف وذلك بعيده اعلان قوات مواليه
لموسكو ان المدينه باتت محاصره
عمليا
يدافعون عن البلاد في اصعب الظروف على
الخطوط الاماميه لقد قدمت جوائز رسميه
وشكرت جنودنا على شجاعتهم وعلى صمود
لاوكرانيا التي نحميها بفض هؤلاء الابطال
وبفضل كل من يحارب الشر الروسي
اكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تقديرات
الاستخبارات البريطانيه بان القدرات
الهجوميه الروسيه ببخمت في تناقص لكنها
اشارت ايضا الان القتال الشرسه مستمر
وذكرت هيئه الاركاي الاوكرانيه ان روسيا
نفذت 48 غاره جويه وخمسا وسبعين هجوم بل
75 هجوما صاروخيا في الساعات الاخيره في
احدث موجه من الضربات الروسيه واشارت الى
ان سلاح الجو استهدف مجمع للصواريخ
الروسيه المضاده للطائرات ياتي هذا بينما
قالت الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان روسيا
تمكنت من قتال او تمكنت بعد قتال عنيف منذ
بدايه الشهر الجاري من السيطره على مناطق
قريبه والمداخل المؤديه لمدينه كريمينا
على خط المواجهه
واشارت في بيان الى ان روسيا حققت تقدما
بعده كيلومترات باتجاه مركز كريمينا وتخطط
للتوسع غربا وصولا الى نهر اوسكول لتعزيز
خطوط الدفاع ولفتت ايضا الى احتمال ات الى
احتمالات بنيه روسيا استعاده مدينه
كوبيانسك في اهميه الاستراتيجيه واكدت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان الوضع
العملياتي في الجبهات الشمالي الشرقيه
يشير الى اندونيسيا تتخذ وضعا دفاعيا
للحفاظ على المكاسب مع اي هجوم اوكراني
كبير
قال قائد القوات الجويه المركزيه
الامريكيه جنرال اليكسا ان الطائرات
الحربيه الروسيه اخترقت المجال الجويه
لقاعده التنف الامريكيه في جنوب سوريا
خمسا هذا الشهر وهو ما وصفه بالعمل
الاستفزازي واضاف ان طائرات روسيه مسلحه
حلقت على ارتفاع منخفض فوق قاعده التنفس
كل يوم تقريبا في مارس منتهكه بذلك اتفاقا
عمره اربع سنوات بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا ما يهدد بالتصعيد واعتبر جنرال
الامريكي ان اتخاذ الروسي موقفا اكثر
عدوانيه ياتي في توقيت غريب وقد يكون من
اجل الضغط على الوجود العسكري الامريكي في
سوريا
وصفت البحريه الامريكيه بيان الجيش الصيني
بشان ابعاد مدمره امريكيه من البحر
الجنوبي بانه خاطئ وغير دقيق واشارت في
بيان ان المدمره الامريكيه انهت عملياتها
الروتينيه ولم يتم طردها وانها ستواصل
البحار والعمل اينما كان وفقان القانون
الدولي وكان الجيش الصيني قال انه قام
بمراقبه وابعاد مدمره امريكيه دخلت المياه
بشكل غير قانوني حول جزر بارسيل
باراسيل في بحر الصين الجنوبي
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
الاسرائيليون غاضبون من تغيير النظام
القضائي يحتشدون امام مطار تل ابيب لعقاره
سفر نتنياهو الى لندن
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد احتشد المحتجون
الاسرائيليون على تغيير النظام القضائي
امام مطار تل ابيب في محاوله لعرقله سفر
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى لندن وتعطيه
الحياه المدنيه في اسرائيل حيث ستسعى
الاحتياجات التي وصفت بانها يوم وطني
للشلل ستسعى الى تعطيل حركه المرور على
الطرق السريعه الرئيسيه وتحديد حول مطار
بنغاريون تحسبا لرحله الى لندن وهذا اليوم
هو الخميس الثالث على التوالي الذي يسعون
فيه الى نسخ خطط رئيس الوزراء لقضاء عطله
نهايه الاسبوع في اوروبا
مشاهدينا من القدسات العربيه لنقل اهلا بك
لانا وبدايه لنا كيف بدت شوارع المدن
الاسرائيليه في هذا اليوم الاحتجاجات وما
الذي يميز ايضا هذه احتياجات عن ما سبقها
صحيح نحن نشهد او فعليا اسرائيل تشهد
اعداد كبيره من المتظاهرين اليوم
المتظاهرين اطلقوا على هذا اليوم يوم
الشلل الوطني اي يريدون فعليا شل حركه
السير بشكل كلي في مناطق مختلفه في
اسرائيل نحن نتحدث عن انطلاق المتظاهرين
باكثر من 180 منطقه ومدن وشوارع مختلفه في
اسرائيل ابرز هذه المناطق سوف تكون ايضا
مطار بن غوريون الدولي في تل ابيب وايضا
منطقه بني بريك بني براك قربه الابيب وهذه
المنطقه تحديدا هي تعرف بانها من يسكن
فيها هم اكثرهم من اليهود المتدينين سوف
يتوجه ايضا اعداد كبيره الى هذه المنطقه
ايضا نتحدث عن تواجد ايضا جنود من
الاحتياط الاسرائيلي في تواجدوا في ميناء
اجداد منذ صباح اليوم قاموا باشعال ايضا
نحن نتحدث يعني عن بدء عمليات شغب حسب ما
يصفها ايضا الشرطه الاسرائيليه حينما يريد
المتظاهرين باغلاق الطرق وهذا ما ايضا
يقومون بالتخطيط له شاهدنا ايضا في مرات
الاخيره حين تظاهر اعداد كبيره بالمئات
الالاف من المتظاهرين تواجدوا في مناطق
مختلفه من تل ابيب القدس وايضا شوارع
النقب نحن نتحدث ايضا عن تواجد اعداد
كبيره اليوم شاهدناها في في مناطق مختلفه
في تل ابيب وايضا كان هناك اعتقال ثمان
متظاهرين من قبل الشرطه الاسرائيليه حسب
شهود عيان من قبل الاسرائيليين يقولون انه
تم هناك اشتباكات بين الجنود وعدد من
المتظاهرين ما ادى الى اعتقال ثمانيه من
المتظاهرين الاسرائيليين صباح اليوم
قبل قليل هل تاتي هذه المشاركه في هذه
التظاهرات بمباركه من المؤسسه العسكريه
اما انها تاتي في سياق حاله التمرد التي
هدد بها هؤلاء الجنود في
مناسبات سابقه
صحيح يعني بدا جنود الاحتياط من الدخول في
موضوع التظاهرات ايضا شاهدنا فقط اليوم
كان هناك انضمام اكثر من 100 جندي في
الاحتياط الى هذه المظاهرات ايضا يعني بغض
النظر عن المظاهرات كان هناك اعلان من قبل
ايضا فتيه يبلغ اعمارهم ثمانيه عشر او
عشرين عاما يقولون في
المتظاهرات واعلنوا انهم سوف يبلغ الشرطه
انهم لن يقوموا بالانضمام الى الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهذه نشير الى انها ايضا خدمه
اجباريه في اسرائيل لدى الشباب وايضا
الفتيات ويعني اعداد كبيره ايضا من الشبان
بداوا يعني يشيرون الى رفضهم في الانضمام
الى الانضمام الى هذا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يصفونه بانه ديكتاتوري ايضا وصفوا هناك
اعداد كبيره منهم ان هذا الجيش ايضا هو
جيش محتل يحتل الضفه الغربيه اولا يشاركوا
في هذا النوع من الخدمه
ونكون في متابعه معك خلال هذا اليوم لاي
تفاصيل حول هذه التظاهرات من القد كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه لانا نكون شكرا لنا
والى فرنسا مشاهدينا حيث لاقى حديث الرئيس
الفرنسي منويل ماكرون عن قانون اصلاح
التقاعد لاقى ردود فعل غاضبه وممدده وذلك
بعد حديثه للمره الاولى منذ دلاع
الاحتياجات عن اصراره على تطبيق اصلاح
نظام التقاعد اذا شدد ماكرون على اهميه ان
يدخل اصلاح نظام التقاعد حيز التنفيذ
بحلول نهايه هذا العام معتبرا انه ضروري
وذلك خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه وبينما لا
تزال تتواصل الاحتجاجات في الشوارع تجهز
النقابات اليوم لاضراب عام وتظاهرات حيث
تخطط النقابات العماليه اليوم الخميس في
200 بلده بل 200 بلديه في فرنسا لتنظيم
احتجاجها التاسع والاضخم ضد اصلاح سن
التقاعد في تحرك وصفته وسائل اعلام
بالخميس الاسود نتابع
ليس واقعيا متعجرف هذه بعض من الاوصاف
التي اجتاحت الوسط السياسي المعارضه في
فرنسا بعد كلام الرئيس ايمانويل وحديثه عن
تمسكه بقانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
مره جديده يتحدث رئيس الجمهوريه لكي لا
يقول شيئا ومما فهمناه نجد فقط علامات
الازدراء التقليديه التي ما يزال يرهقنا
بها الى الان
تتفق معه زعيمه اقصى اليمين مارين لوبين
رئيس
لايجاد الكلمات التي تطمئن وتوحد اليوم
عزز السيد مكرون شعوره لزراء لجزء من
الناس شعور الازدراء هذا انسحب على الشارع
حيث تسيطر شريحه الطلاب عليهم منذ سته
ايام ما دفع ماكرون لوصف تحركهم بانه غير
شرعي فبدات عمليات عصيان في الجامعات وصل
عددها حتى الان الى 60 جامعه في كل فرنسا
وهو تحرك انطلق من جامعه السوربون التي
طوقتها الشرطه اعلم في العاده ننسق
تحركاتنا مع النقابات لكننا الان نتحرك من
تلقاء انفسنا لان الشباب فهموا انه اذا لم
يتحركوا من اجل مستقبلهم فلن يتحرك احد من
اجلهم خلال الحديث مع ريتشي استوقفنا جاره
الكهل مثنيا على تحرك الطلاب في الشارع
ومعتبرا ان الشعب هو القانون وليس ما
يحاول ماكرون تطبيقه
الشباب يبعثون الخوف في قلب السلطه كبار
السن مث
لكن الشباب لا يمكن السيطره عليهم
عدم سيطره الشرطه على احتجاجات الشباب كان
واضحا من خلال تمكنهم من تحويل ليل فرنسا
الى نهار فراحوا يشعلون الحرائق في
الشوارع وهذا ليس الافتعال الشغب كما
يقولون وانما لعرقله الشرطه التي تلهث
خلفهم وتخاطر بان يكون الوضع اسوا عندما
سيجتمع هؤلاء الطلاب مع النقابيين الذين
اعدوا العده للخميس الاسود
فدهوك العربيه باريس ومن باريس مشاهدينا
انضموا الينا مراسله العربيه زين عادي
اهلا بك زينه وهل اكملت النقابات الفرنسيه
استعداداتها لهذا اليوم وما الذي تشير
اليه التوقعات زينه
نعم صباح الخير في الواقع منذ الساعات
الاولى من الصباح بدات تتكشف حركه
الاحتجاجيه على الارض هناك قطع للطرق
السريعه من قبل المتظاهرين يقفون هناك
وايضا في محطه مطار محطه قطار هنا في
باريس بالنسبه للمحتجين ايضا سيضربون في
عده قطاعاتك التعليم وايضا في حركه النقل
العام ستكون شبه معطله الحركه على الارض
واسعه وكبيره في اليوم التاسع من هذا
الحراك الوطني
العام بالنسبه ايضا للمظاهره التي ستنطلق
اليوم من قبل النقابات التي دعت اليها
النقابات ستنطلق في باريس عند الساعه
الثانيه بعد الظهر
وستنتهي من المقرر ان تنتهي عند الساعه
السابعه مساء لكن من المتوقع ان تكون
اليوم يعني التظاهرات عنيفه اكثر من
الصادق باعتبار بان هذه التظاهره الاولى
التي
دعت اليها نقابات التي ستكون بعد خطاب
الرئيس اليوم الشارع يغلي بشكل كبير
بحسب يعني الاستطلاعات تبين بان 61% من
الفرنسيين يرون بان خطاب ماكرون في الامس
الشارع الفرنسي واحد من اصل اثنين ايضا من
الفرنسيين يرى بان خطاب ماكرون ليس مقنع
ولا ولم يخفف من حده خطابه في الامس مكروه
من طرفه كان في الامس حازما وواضحا بان
مشروع قانون رفع سن التقاعد سوف يطبق في
نهايه هذا العام وهذا يعني بان الشارع
سيبقى مشتعلا حتى ان يجد النقابات حلا في
اليوم لان اليوم سيكون هناك يعني
نقاشات بين النقابات وسنرى ان كان
سيستمرون في هذا الحراك على الارض ام ان
هناك مخطط اخر بالنسبه لهم وماذا عن احزاب
المعارضه ودورها في هذه المظاهرات اليوم
اللجوءها الى تحشيد الشارع يدل على انها
استنفذت جميع خياراتها واوراقها السياسيه
ام ان لديها خيارات اخرى ايضا
بالضبط حتى الاحزاب السياسيه المعارضه
للرئيس ماكرون تقوم بحشد جهودها وحشد
المناصرها للتحرك اليوم الى جانب النقابات
في الامس كان هناك تصريحات ناريه من قبل
يعني زعماء هذه المعارضه اعتبروا بان ما
يقوله الرئيس ماكرون هو ازدراء للشارع
الفرنسي وبانه لا يستمع الى الحركه
الاحتجاجيه والى صوت الشباب بالنسبه لهذه
الحركه هناك حراك كبير من قبل الشباب
الفرنسي وهذا يعني بان مستقبل البلاد قادم
نحو اضطرابات اكبر لذلك الاحزاب اليوم
ستنضم الى هذه التظاهرات وربما هم يعتبرون
بان لا نقاش مره اخرى مع الرئيس ماكرون
كونه يعني بث في الامس بقراره بانه يكمل
طريق هذا
القانون من دون الرجوع الى الشعب مره اخرى
اذا
من باريس طيب قبل ان اختم معك لدينا الوقت
واعود ان اسالك ايضا عن بعض الملاحظات
التي يبيح بعض المراقبين وهو تعامل الشرطه
الفرنسيه مع المتظاهرين يصفون ذلك
بالتعامل العنيف هل يعد ذلك التعامل مبررا
قانونيا ام ينظر اليه كتجاوز بحق هؤلاء
المتظاهرين
بالنسبه لمنظمه العفو الدوليه اصدرت في
الامس يعني بيانا تقول بان يعني دعت فرنسا
ان تخفف من عنفها دعت الشرطه الفرنسيه ان
تخفف من عوفها وانتقدت هذا النوع من اخماد
المظاهرات لكن بالنسبه للحكومه الفرنسيه
هي تعتبر بان التظاهرات التي تخرج بشكل
عشوائي وبشكل عفوي وتقوم بالتخريب في في
الشوارع الفرنسيه هي ايضا
تدعو الى العنف وهي بنسبه للحكومه هي
مضطره بان تخرج العناصر الشرطه الى الشارع
ولتحاول ضبط امن الشوارع لكن يعني يبدو
بان هناك مواجهات عنيفه بين الطرفين ايض
الشرطه تستخدم الهراوات وتستخدم الغاز
المسيله للدموع ايضا المتظاهرين بعض
المتظاهرين يقومون باحراق النفايات
المتراكمه في الشوارع وهذا ما يزيد الوضع
سوءا والشرطه الفرنسيه اليوم ستحتجد حوالي
000 شرطي سيكون ودرك سيكون منتشر في في
البلاد وايضا 5000 منهم سيكون في باريس
نعم
لكل هذه مجرد هذه التظاهرات في العاصمه
باريس وبقيت المدن
الفرنسيسه العربيه زين عادي شكرا لك زينه
مشاهدينا دعى رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه عبد الحميد الديبابه الى تغريب
لغه الحوار من اجل اتاحه الفرصه لاجراء
الانتخابات في البلاد الدببه دعا كل من
يؤيد حكومته او يعارضها الى العمل على
توحيد المؤسسه العسكريه وعدم عوده الحرب
معتبرا ان تهيئه الظروف لاجراء الانتخابات
يحتاج لتغريب لغه الحوار وتوسيع قاعده
المشاركه
اكد رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد العزم على
مواصله ما وصفه بالمعركه ضد الفساد
ومقاومه الضغوطات التي تتعرض اليها تونس
من الداخل والخارج حسب وصفه
نحن عازمون بفضل الله تعالى على
مواصله ما بداناه من معركه ضد الفساد وكم
من ايه ورد فيها الفساد
في الارض وفي البحر
سنحارب معا
مؤمنين مخلصين لله ولا الشعب التونسي
ونطلب من الله العون حتى تعلوه كلمه الحق
والعدل
ويسهل ويزهق الباطل في الداخل وفي الخارج
على السواعد
قال عضو مجلس السياده الانتقالي السوداني
الفريق ياسر العطاء انه لابد بمواصله
اصلاح المنظومه العسكريه مشيرا الى ان
الخطوه الاولى فيها تاسيس جيش قومي واحد
مستقل وقوي واعتماد منظومه عالميه في
تركيبه الجيش وعديده مقارنه بعدد سكان
البلاد والمهددات المحيطه بها داخليا
وخارجيا ونسبه كل اقليم في الجيش والكليات
الحربيه وهذا يتطلب مواصله اصلاح منظومتنا
العسكريه
والخطوه الاولى فيها
تاسيس الجيش الرومي واحد مستغل وغوي
ثم الخطوه الثانيه
لتمتد مسيره الاصلاح حتى يرى كل سوداني كل
سوداني نفسه
داخل جيشه
وهذا يتاتى فقط بالرجوع للمعايير الدوليه
المعروفه في عدد وحجم الجيش
والذي يحسب
بعدد سكان الدوله
ومساحتها وناتجها القومي
والمهددان المحيطه بها داخليا وخارجيا
وهي لذلك
خطوه مهمه هي نسبه كل اغليم في الجيش
والكليات الحربيه
نشاطها مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
اول صاروخ مصنوع بطباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد
يفشل في بلوغ مطر
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد مسار غير معهود
رئيس ليس كغيره ممن حكموا البيت الابيض
دونالد ترامب امام عقباتنا قضائيه لا
تنتهي في الوقت الذي ترتفع فيه حمى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي يلعب جزء هام
منها داخل قاعه مداوله محكمه نيويورك
قضيه واحده اعادت فتح 4000 قضيه اخرى
دونالد ترامب الرئيس الذي غادر المنصب ولم
يختفي من المشهد الاعلامي بعد اتهام ترامب
الرئيس وترامب رجل الاعمال جاء دور ترامب
المترشح ليدخل المحاكم القضيه تعود الى
عام 2016 حين اتهمت ممثله اباحيه ترامب
بشراء صمتها خوفا من فضيحه تعكر حملته
الانتخابيه القضيه كانت اقرب الى مجرد
تسويه شخصيه الا ان شهاده صديق سابق جاءت
لتغير مسار التحقيق ميشيل كوهين محامي
ترامبي السابق اعترف دفع شخصيا 130 الف
دولار لتسويه القضيه من اموال حمله موكله
الانتخابيه ترامب لا يواجه التهمه للمره
الاولى الا انه سيقف هذه المره امام محكمه
نيويورك التي يسيطر عليها مدعي عام
الديمقراطي حتى النخاع القضيه احيت قضايا
سابقه ومعها جدوى رئيس لا تنقصه المشاكل
بعضها تم تصنيفها كتهم جنائيه وتكفي ادانه
واحده لتنسفه طموحاته السياسيه
بايادي مكبله قد يقف اول رئيس امريكي امام
محكمه جنائيه الا ان سمعه رئيس سابق لا
تهم ترامبو انصاره بقدر سمعه مترشح
للانتخابات المقبله
اتهم الديمقراطيين باستغلال النفوذ لتسييس
القضيه وهي الحجه التي استغلها للاعب
ورقته المفضله المتمثله بدعوه الانصار
للاعتصام انصار الحزب الجمهوري وان لم يعد
ترامب يحظى بالاجماع بينهم الا انهم
اعتبروه نفقا مظلما عبور ترامب منه بسلام
سيقوده الى البيت الابيض من الباب الواسع
الى لبنان حيث وعادت التحركات الى ساحه
رياض الصلح احتجاجا على عدم استقرار سعر
الصرف وعدم اتخاذ الحكومه اجراءات للحد من
الانهيار وضمه التحركات متقاعدي الجيش
وقوى الامن والجمارك الذين حاولوا اقتحام
السراي الحكومي
المواطنين اللبنانيين بالقنابل المسيله
ورغم ان اكثريه المتظاهرين الذين توافدوا
الى ساحه رياض الصلح كانوا من المتقاعدين
الا ان كبر السن لم يقف عائقا امام
استخدام القوه لمنعهم اجتياز الحاجز
المؤدي الى
الحق بالطبابه والتعليم اضافه الى المطالب
المعيشيه التي زادها سوءا الانهيار
الصاروخي لليره اللبنانيه كانت الجامعه
بين مجموعات اختلفت انتمائها
سرقونا وسرقوا جنى عمرنا ومستقبلنا
ومستقبل اولادنا هولي لصوص اللي جوا انا
جاي شاري كطالب ثانوي انه اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر مدربين والوزير بعده غيب لا حلول ولا
شيء
ولا ممكن نقبل هالحكي
وبالتزامن مع تحركات الشارع عقدت اللجان
النيابيه جلسه مناقشه لمسائله الحكومه
ومصرف لبنان وجمعيه المصارف عن الخطوات
التي فشلت باتخاذها وفيما حضر ممثل عن
رئيس الحكومه وحاكم المصرف غابت جمعيه
المصارف دون اي مبرر لاحد اجوبه
انه انا اليوم اذا اضطريت اجي اذا ما رحنا
عندي عجز بالموازنه راح نكمل طبع ميل طبعا
بالمجلس قلت له وقفت انا اعترض قلت له اول
شيء مش هيك بيحكى عن طباعه الليره
اللبنانيه لانه واحده من الاسباب الاساسيه
انهيار هو الطباعه اسهل شيء ندفع معاشات
القطاع الخاص اول شيء القطاع العام اول
شيء بتعيده هيكله القطاع العام تاني شيء
بتوقفوا التهريب بتحسنوا الايرادات
الموازنه لليوم اتقدمت ارتفاع سعر الصرف
بنسبه 12 في المئه خلال يوم واحد حرك
الشارع اللبناني لكن الدعوات الى الاضراب
لم تلقى اذانا صغيره ولم تلتزم الصيدليات
بقرار النقابه التي دعت الى الاغلاق
احتجاجا على عدم تسليم الشركات للادويه
اما المصارف وامام الارتفاع الصاروخي
للدولار فتراجعت عن اضرابها المفتوح الذي
تشهره سلاحا في كل مره يقف فيها القضاء
بصف المذيعين هي المطالب نفسها وحدت اكثر
من مجموعه امام السرايا الحكومي الذي يمثل
حكومه ادارت اذانها الصماء دون اتخاذ اي
اجراء اصلاحي يضع حدا لتعدديه سعر الصرف
التي كانت سببا اساسيا لضرب القدره
الشرائيه غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت رمضان
صعب اذا ينتظر السوريين في بلده جنديرس في
محافظه حلب السوريه حيث تضررت البلده بشده
من الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب البلاد في
فبراير الماضي فيما يعيش الكثير من اهل
البلده في خيام مؤقته وظروف معاشيه قاسيه
[موسيقى]
يعني متشردين ما في استقرار بقى انا يعني
بعجز على انه هو كل عام وانتم بخير ابدا
وما اننا مرتاحين بالخيار
[موسيقى]
علينا
وخرب بيتنا كله بالارض
وجاء شهر رمضان الكريم
رحنا شوي جبنا الغرض من السوق بس رمضان مو
مثل قبل سنه الماضيه والثانيه هاي السنه
صار صعبه علينا يعني نفسيتنا انكسر
صعب كثير هذا شهر رمضان الله يجعله خير
يعني بس صعب كتير اعدي علينا شرحت لك يعني
بين الفرق البيت وبين خيمه كتير صعبه بدي
قنينه
وبدي علبه تامر
[موسيقى]
يستعد المغاربه لشهر رمضان الفضيل بالحرص
على شراء مكونات اعداد ما يهم الشهر
الفضيل من اطباق تراثيه الى جانب الحاجيات
الاساسيه من خبار وفواكه ويشتكي المغاربه
من موجه غلاء جديده ضربت الاسواق واثرت
على مصروف الاستعداد للشهر الفضيله
مع قدوم شهر رمضان توافد المواطنين
المغاربه على الاسواق لشراء متطلبات الشعر
من الفواكه الجافه والتمور والحبوب القاسم
المشترك بين الجميع الشكوى من الغلاء
درهم بطبيعه الحال غادي تحيد النص بالنسبه
للقفه ديال رمضان
هذا العام بالاخص استثنائي
بالباقي السنوات الفارطه بالنسبه للزياره
اللي كاينه في الاسعار على سعيد جميع
المواد الغذائيه من البيض اللي وصل لدرهم
ونص حتى للحب اللي ما بقاش قدرنا نشريوه
يحرس مصطفى على الاعتناء بسلاح شهر رمضان
ارضاء لزبناء محله في هذا السوق الشعبي في
العاصمه الرباط داعيا للمغاربه الى تسوق
يتماشى مع القدره الشرائيه
في المواسم ديالهم ديما الناس كيديروا
العواشر كما كانت هي هذه
والانسان كيما الناس على النظام كاين اللي
كيدير شويه كاين الناس
كل القدره الاشتيره ديالو القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين المغاربه تقص مؤخرا خصوصا في
هذه الاعوام الاخيره لواحد الدرجه لان
كاين شي مواد اللي تزاد فيها تقريبا نص
بالنص ديما في العواشر ديال رمضان كيكون
واحد الاقبال على المواد الاوليه
جولاتهم اليوميه للتسوق الرمضاني وسط
رسائل تطمين من الحكومه بقرب تراجع
الاسعار يشتكي المواطنون المغاربه من موجه
غلاء يقولون انها غير مسبوقه تضرب الاسواق
المغربيه فيما يتحدث التجار عن وفره في
السلع وبان الاثمنه في المتناول هذا هو
المشهد في الاسواق الشعبيه المغربيه مع
اقتراب شهر رمضان عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط
[موسيقى]
وقبل نهايه هذه النشاط المشاهدين نذكر
بابرز العناوين
يحضر الغرب ويقول ان نهايه العالم اصبحت
نوويه ويتواعد بحرب المدمره اذا اعتقل
بوتين
الجيش الصيني تاهب ويعلن ابعاد مدمره
امريكيه من بحر من البحر الجنوبي واشنطن
تنفي
وزير الخارجيه السعودي يتفق مع نظيره
الايراني على لقاء قريب تمهيدا
تحرك شعبي فرنسي غاض ضد قانون التقاعد
والسلطات تستعد للخميس الاسود
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]